all right a very busy political week
let's go to the phones and see what's on
people's minds at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's start with our caller from the 7 7
3 area code who's calling from 7 7 3
today 7 7 3
yes go ahead hi um yeah my question is
basically about Democratic primaries I
want to know what what do you think that
is going June the mainstream is going to
get behind Bernie and start supporting
him because I'm seeing headlines like uh
Kim Sanders maintain this momentum or
you know San Fran New Hampshire shows
that there's a split in the Democratic
Party like do you think there is a point
after you know X amount of primaries
where they're gonna start getting behind
him and actually being supportive no
probably not I um I don't think that
they're going to know I I think that
really the question is when when will
the court legacy corporate media and DNC
decide is is Biden their candidate or is
it going to be
Pete Budaj edge or a me or if Michael
Bloomberg does well on Super Tuesday
will they switch to Bloomberg but I
don't expect them to get behind Bernie
at any point soon are you I mean are you
in favor of Bernie I know you you made
video saying you're not a socialist but
I mean is Bernie your pick
yes yes yes I you said earlier this week
at this point in the Massachusetts
primary I plan to vote for Bernie I
believe that at this point this is a
race between Biden maybe although
increasingly he's not going to be a
factor Pete Budaj edge
I do believe Bloomberg is going to end
up third or fourth in delegates so yeah
these are the people that basically now
are this is this is down too so I'll be
voting for Bernie in the primary okay
and the last question I have kind of a
silly one I've only been a fan for a few
months so I don't know maybe you've
covered this but did anyone make fun of
your last name sorry did anyone like
your connection is maybe a 5 out of 10
did someone make fun of my last name
yeah when you were younger
you know people would say oh did your
dad invent the videogame or whatever and
for a while it annoyed me and then
eventually I would say yes he did
complete I would just say yes he did and
then it very quickly ended the
conversation all right thanks appreciate
the phone call as many of you know I am
super careful about where we publish and
distribute david pakman show content
it's a really important decision that we
make where do we want our content to be
we don't want to spread ourselves too
thin but we want to make sure that we're
taking advantage of good platforms where
our content could do well and over the
last couple of months I've been testing
publishing our content to a platform
called library that's lbr why I've
mentioned it once or twice before and we
are absolutely loving it it's a
fantastic platform where our revenue as
publishers does not depend on some
algorithm deciding whether an ad should
run before a video or not in fact it's
actually an ad-free platform where our
revenue is determined by the number of
people that watch our videos and also by
the tips better left for us in credits
that are in platform credits it's their
own sort of currency so to speak by
viewers like you
and right now for people who sign up on
this platform it's completely free using
the link down in the video description
for every verified sign up we get a
little bit of a credit and you also get
a credit of tips that you can then leave
on content that you like such as the
david pakman show content that we are
publishing so use the link down in the
video description
no algorithmic determinations about
whether we get to make money or we don't
get to make money or any of that stuff
all of our video content is being
published there use that link sign up
you'll get a credit we'll get a credit
and it's a beautiful thing and I'll
update you guys in a couple of weeks
about how it's going there's also a
contest that they're running who ever
can refer the most new users gets a huge
reward which would be a big big boost to
us so check it out link down in the
video description
let me know what you think